a man accused of opening fire on the las
vegas trip is telling the i-team that
this was all self-defense
a news now first brought to you video
showing how this all unfolded
now malik frost is talking only to my
colleague vanessa murphy who's here with
more on what he said vanessa
malik frost says he's the victim here
while the way he explains it
while the way he explains what happened
sounds like self-defense
police and prosecutors call it murder
if convicted he could face a life
sentence
that was malik frost on april 25th on
the las vegas strip
now he's in jail charged with murder
attempted murder and battery
frost talked with the i-team from the
clark county detention center
[Applause]
i just hope the truth will prevail the
i-team obtained these videos at the
center of the case showing how it all
unfolded
while frost says he was with his fiancee
who was having a medical emergency
another woman testified in front of the
grand jury she was frustrated they took
so long in a bathroom stall
and told her fiance daryl white frost
and his fiancee leave
so does the other woman white end the
group there with
a confrontation continues outside and
escalates quickly
i feel as i acted as any law-abiding
citizen would who
had the legal right to carry a firearm
frost says he was outnumbered
people are seen backing up as frost
moves toward them
the fight turns physical metro police
say this is when frost
shoots white the i-team has chosen not
to air the full videos
the 26 year old las vegas man was
pronounced
dead at the hospital a security guard
urges people nearby to stay inside
william malloy testified in front of the
grand jury he
throws a rocket frost to be a hero frost
is hit in the head
he turns and shoots again according to
malloy he was hit six
times and now uses a walker and
wheelchair
i was also put in the hospital i mean i
got hit with a very large rock
i've had to get nine stitches a major
concussion
you know i mean like i said i tried to
do everything and avoid it
do you wish you just kept walking away
though
to the surviving man and the family
of the man who didn't survive
i would rather not speak on it video
shows the woman who frost calls his
fiancee being confrontational and
stumbling
i got you on my camera this witness
follows the couple
innocent man frost puts his hand on his
gun again
but doesn't shoot he just sat somebody
he got a gun
he threatened me frost is scheduled to
appear in court on july
9. he's being held with no bond he's
charged with five felonies one count of
murder two counts of attempted murder
and two counts of battery